hi everybody dr sammy here your friendly
neighborhood entomologist and i was
hoping that we could take a few minutes
to talk about adaptation
what comes to mind when you think about
adaptation
you might think of cryptic morphology
that helps organisms hide from predators
scaly armor or spines to protect
organisms in a scuffle or increased
melanin pigmentation in the skin to
shield an organism from the damaging
impacts of harsh sunlight in really
sunny areas
and if this is the sort of thing that
you thought of you're right these are
all adaptations but what people often
miss about adaptations is that they all
help organisms survive and reproduce
in a particular environment the word
adaptation
can refer to
a trait
that makes an organism
more suited to its environment
but it can also mean
the process
by which a population becomes
dominated by organisms that are suited
to their environment the point is that
adaptation happens in a population as
its organisms accumulate adaptations
and this all happens through the process
of natural selection which you may have
heard about with natural selection we
see organisms with beneficial heritable
traits increasing their share of the
gene pool in the population because
they're more likely to mate and produce
offspring
this means these well-adapted organisms
have higher fitness
a measure
of an organism's
ability to
survive
and reproduce in its specific
environment these traits or adaptations
make the organisms better suited to
survive and reproduce because they're
better suited to the specific
environmental context that they live in
that is our green caterpillars blend in
and thus survive better on the green
leaves and the orange caterpillars on
the orange leaves as you can see natural
selection is intimately intertwined with
the environment in which it takes place
and this is why natural selection can
lead to adaptation
even the concept of adaptation is
diverse
adaptations can be anatomical
changes to physical structures
or physiological changes in the function
of these structures
or
adaptations can be changes to behavior
we see this with honeybees adapted to
life in africa
sometimes called by the suboptimal names
africanized honeybees or killer bees
they're the same species as and look
identical to populations of honeybees
adapted to north america but their
behaviors diverge dramatically
because the african populations are
adapted to life in a hot tropical
environment sometimes they construct
nests right out in the open air nests in
open air
this is extremely rare for populations
adapted to the temperate climate of
north america where the temperature
range is far too broad between winter
and summer for open-air nests to be
successful
so north american honeybee populations
much prefer to live inside of protected
structures like inside the trunks of
hollow trees or the boxes that
beekeepers provide
nests in
protected structures
and in africa there are also more large
fearsome predators interested in getting
into the bees nest so the frequency of
traits related to hyper defensiveness is
much more common than in populations
adapted to north america where there are
fewer aggressive predators
heightened defensiveness
low
to
moderate
defensiveness
the success of honeybees adapted to life
in africa left a lot of people worried
that they would be similarly successful
in north america and replace the
honeybees there but those concerns
ignored the connection between
adaptation and the environment
traits that helped those bees survive in
africa and even help them in similar
environments found in many regions of
tropical south and central america well
those same exact traits were liabilities
in much of north america okay so this is
all fascinating but you may be wondering
if natural selection is passing out
adaptations why doesn't it choose better
stuff
fish tend to get eaten by birds and
bears
a lot and that's gone on for literally
millions of years so why haven't fish
populations developed something like
laser eyes or
teleportation instead when a population
of fish does evolve defense it's
typically something like a few bones
that it already has getting longer and
sharper and protruding out of their fins
like in the case of the three-spined
stickleback fish
these spines protect the stickleback
from
birds and other predators but only if
the spines are long enough to make it
difficult for that specific predator to
swallow them birds with wider throats
are still able to eat even fully grown
fish with fully elongated spines laser
eyes really do seem like they would be
more effective
it's almost like natural selection is
just tinkering with whatever it has
lying around instead of going out and
buying something new and perfectly
suited to the task
and that is exactly what's happening
populations don't adapt by accessing a
bottomless well of awesome
problem-solving options quite the
contrary with natural selection as the
driver adaptations can be pretty limited
you might already be tracking with the
idea that if an increase in fitness is
what natural selection is after you
don't need an adaptation that allows you
to incinerate all of your enemies you
just need one good enough to solve
whatever problem is keeping others in
your population from surviving and
mating if that's a kingfisher bird
eating the other fish the resolution
might be just a spine that's only half a
centimeter longer than the other fishes
that's the reason why we see adaptations
that look like natural selection just
grabbed whatever happened to be lying
around and modified it because it kinda
did
a turtle's remarkably protective shell
may look fancy and novel but it's
literally the turtle's overgrown ribs
fused with its spine a narwhal's face
spear
that there is just a tooth that grew all
the way out of its face
natural selection only has the options
currently in the genes of a population
with the occasional addition of new
genetic sequences through mutation to
work with when a problem arises and you
might be thinking oh great mutations
those will help that's how my favorite
superhero got her powers
well
unlike what we see in movies most
mutations either have no real effect or
result in problematic gene expression or
non-functional proteins which is pretty
pretty bad news for living things so
adaptations are not likely to be super
weapons that ensure survival in all
circumstances instead they're useful
traits that help increase an organism's
fitness as the environmental conditions
apply pressure so adaptation is a
remarkable system but one with some
pretty pronounced limitations
natural selection has to work with what
an organism has but consider for a
moment what it has given us despite
those limitations
pistol shrimp have the ability to slam
their claw shut so quickly that the
water around them collapses in on itself
it implodes knocking nearby fish
unconscious
some honeybees can bundle together and
vibrate their flight muscles so rapidly
that they can create a biological
convection oven which can cook predators
to death and there are parasitic wasps
that have evolved to live inside of
parasitic wasps that live inside of
parasitic wasps that live inside of
caterpillars like like tiny strange
little russian nesting dolls and don't
even get me started on the hornets that
have yellow patches on their abdomen
that absorb solar energy to supplement
the energy provided by their diet they
have solar panels
i'd say natural selection has done
pretty well for itself